Moscow is back in lockdown today as a
daily covid-19 deaths hit another new
record of over 1100 on Thursday
President Vladimir Putin has ordered
Russians to take a week off work and
impose restrictions on public Gatherings
when the capital Moscow all
non-essential services are closed for
the next 11 days despite the surge in
cases the majority of Russians have yet
to heed urgent calls to get vaccinated
laughs
a new day a new tragic record as the
highly infectious Delta variant
continues to spread Russia's coveted
Wards continued to fill primarily with
the unvaccinated
[Music]
patients infected with the coronavirus
have become a fixture on Russian news
programs but they have done little to
convince a skeptical population to get
vaccinated forcing the Authority's hand
moscow's mayor joined other Regional
leaders declaring an 11-day soft
lockdown to the Capitol closing bars
cafes theaters and other public spaces
it coincides with a federal week-long
work holiday and stay-at-home orders for
the elderly and vulnerable authorities
hope the short fire break will help them
weather the pandemic's fourth wave
Health experts welcome the announcement
but warn it's too little too late
11 days isn't enough at all it's another
example of a half measure and an attempt
to please everyone
but you have to keep Public Health in
mind in the current situation we can't
use abstractions we're talking about
real deaths real illness and long
covered we have to put a stop to it
vaccinations with Russian maid Sputnik V
have increased in recent weeks thanks to
government mandates and new restrictions
doubling to around three hundred
thousand a day but overall only around a
third of Russians have gotten their
first shot of the rest some say they'd
rather wait for an international vaccine
but around half don't intend to get
vaccinated at all including many medical
personnel provoking growing frustration
among the country's medical community
people aren't behaving correctly
it's sad to see it
Russia produced a great vaccine Sputnik
V
U I have full confidence in Sputnik it's
comparable to vaccines produced in the
west why don't we use it I don't know
frustration is also spreading among many
in the service industry the branch was
especially hard hit by previous lockdown
measures and now they say they're paying
the price for Russia's vaccine hesitancy
and preparing for a Long Winter
we're looking at how we're going to
survive the next lockdown I think
everything is going to be much harder
because everyone understands this is
just the beginning and it could go
beyond the 8th of November but we're
just going to have to deal with it
as the Delta variant continues to spread
government officials warn Russia's
fourth wave is only likely to get worse
and I'm joined Now by DW correspondent
Aaron Tilton in Moscow Aaron great to
see you while in many European countries
death rates are declining Russia has
been reporting the highest death rate
since the start of the pandemic how do
we get to this point
well the situation in Russia is a little
bit different than a lot of other
European countries now we often talk
about the first second third and fourth
wave of covid but as one doctor I spoke
to here put it it's inappropriate to
talk about waves because we're not
seeing Peaks and troughs here instead he
was saying that the infection numbers
especially in Moscow plateaued at a very
very high level in late summer and then
when the Delta variant came it pushed
those numbers up even higher now you
combine that with the country's very low
rate of vaccination and well it's a
recipe for disaster and Aaron why is it
that Russians are so reluctant to get
vaccinated
well that really is the big question and
partially I think it has to do with kind
of a baked in mistrust of the government
government information and of course you
could describe it as cynicism or Russian
fatalism but it really stretched back
decades back into the Soviet era
um so there's that aspect of it at the
same time a lot of medical professionals
I've spoken to have said that the
vaccine roll out and you have to
remember it was the first in the world
you know their vac their massive
vaccination campaign is already 10
months old but the role was rather
half-hearted you didn't necessarily see
the Russian political Elite out there in
front of the cameras getting them
injected and telling people to embrace
the vaccine and that kind of chipped
away a little bit at the public trust
and combined that with the international
communities kind of rejection of Sputnik
V and that all kind of uh paints a
picture of um well kind of eroding
public trust in the vaccine and it's
really kind of a wicked problem from
Moscow because they're telling people
this is the best way to find our way out
of the pandemic but so far people really
aren't willing to get Mass vaccinated in
the way the country needs um let's talk
about one of the breaking points that
many governments around the world are
nervous about is there now a danger at
this point that hospitals could become
overwhelmed
well I would certainly say there is now
we have seen statements from various
different hospitals especially here in
Moscow saying that they're well equipped
to deal with the current patient load
that they are receiving but at the same
time the very fact that we were
returning to a soft lockdown here
indicates that the city government
thinks that these hospitals need a
little bit of a break to catch their
breath one doctor I talked to actually
said that it's less about the free beds
and oxygen and other products they need
and it's more about the doctors
themselves you have to remember a lot of
the doctors here have been working for
18 months at a Breakneck pace and
they're really kind of reaching their
limit and he said you know when you have
tired and overworked doctors that were
that's when mistakes start to happen so
at the moment the very fact that we're
returning to lockdown does seem that
that uh that the city government at
least thinks that the hospitals are in
need of a little bit of a break and a
little bit of a help moving forward all
right Aaron Tilton for us in Moscow
thank you so much for that update
thank you and we can take a look now at
some of the other developments in the
pandemic Singapore is investigating what
it calls an unusual surge of new
covid-19 infections the city-state is
seeing its highest infection figures
since the pandemic began and the health
Ministry says that's despite about 84
percent of the population being fully
vaccinated and New Zealand says it will
begin loosening its border quarantine
requirements once virtually covid-19
free the country had among the toughest
restrictions in the world
China has also placed a third city under
lockdown to tackle covid-19 numbers
which means around 6 million people are
under orders to stay at home
and here in Germany concern is also
growing about a recent sharp rise in the
number of covid-19 infections on
Thursday Germany's Robert Clark
Institute reported 28 000 new
coronavirus cases in the previous 24
hours
the number of people admitted to
hospital intensive care units in the
last week has also risen authorities say
the majority of patients being treated
are unvaccinated and they're warning
that the country is entering a critical
phase in the pandemic
so for more on this I'm joined by our
political correspondent Thomas Sparrow
in Berlin Thomas hi thanks so much for
joining us why are infection numbers in
Germany increasing like this
it's actually a mixture of various
elements on the one hand the fact that
we're approaching the colder months of
the year where people tend to be more
indoors than Outdoors that's one element
that authorities have certainly
mentioned this time around comparing it
also to the situation one year ago when
Germany also saw an increase in the
number of cases as uh the winter
Approach at the same time certain German
states have just come out of their
Autumn holidays so experts have also
stressed that that could be one
additional element to explain why
numbers now are rising and then there's
also the issue of the unvaccinated here
in the country a particular matter of
concern two-thirds of Germans are fully
vaccinated but that leaves one third
that are not vaccinated many of people
are actually reluctant in that group to
actually get a vaccination and this is
something that has authorities concerned
for some time now how to make sure that
that vaccination Ray 8 which yes it may
be more than many countries around the
world but it's not developing as fast as
authorities would like and authorities
are actually struggling to convince the
unvaccinated to take the job so this
these explanations here actually help to
understand why Germany now may be seeing
this High number in infections and also
how authorities may may be reacting in
the next few days in the next few weeks
to make sure that those numbers remain
or at least decrease as much as possible
so Thomas just be clear clear those
one-third who are unvaccinated in
Germany are they the ones who are being
mainly affected by these new coveted
infections
mainly yes but not exclusively so there
is concern
at the number of unvaccinated people but
there's also concern for example at the
number of vaccinated people who have
also now had an infection that is a
matter of concern here in particular
because of those booster jobs that are
also under discussion then there's
concern as well about the number of
children and teenagers who have been
infected in fact Germany's also record
numbers of under 15 year olds who have
been infected in recent days and at the
same time let's not forget that there
are over 9 million children under 12
year old for whom there is no approved
vaccination so these different age
groups are certainly a matter that
authorities are taking very carefully
because they want to understand in
particular how this situation will
impact the overall number of infections
in the country okay so a complicated
picture requiring a government response
now of course dealing with the pandemic
restrictions is still officially the job
of Angela merkel's caretaker government
for the three parties currently holding
Coalition talks say they won't seek to
extend the national state of emergency
that allowed the government to impose
General restrictions let's see if we can
take a look
it seems like these that the three
parties trying to form the next German
government want to avoid lockdown hit
the country hard and I repeat is not an
option
school closures lockdowns and curfews
will in any case no longer happen with
us and are also disproportionate in the
current situation the social Democrats
the greens and the Liberals presented
their plans to deal with the coronavirus
the key measure not to extend the
national state of emergency it allowed
the government to quickly and
controversially impose restrictions
instead affected regions would have
specific measures to deal with a
pandemic that is still not under control
we have a very high number of infections
especially among younger children and we
want to ensure that as much protection
as possible continues to be guaranteed
at the same time of course it's also
about ensuring that our health system is
not overburdened in the future
Germany has seen yet another worrying
increase in the number of infections in
vaccination numbers and not growing as
fast as authorities would like around
two-thirds of Germans are fully
vaccinated and some are worried
of course that's logical everyone will
be worried we don't want to close
everything again we've already had all
that does it I would not have thought it
was possible that it would increase so
much
people should be sensible and really
think about it and actually get
vaccinated
the pandemic will be a key challenge for
the next German government the three
parties hope to sign a coalition
agreement by the end of the year
thanks Thomas for that report um so as
we've heard the three parties hoping to
form a new government want to end the
national state of emergency but have the
recent numbers made them rethink that at
all
well they are obviously concerned about
the current situation that's something
that was also clear from the press
conference when it where they announced
their plans I followed that press
conference but what they pointed out is
that the situation this year the
situation now is different from the
situation let's say a year ago partly
because of the number of people who have
accepted that vaccination and what they
now stress is that that National measure
that national state of emergency is no
longer required instead where they want
to move towards is to have more Regional
or local measures depending on the
number of infections in certain regions
at the same time they also want to make
sure that the German Parliament has a
louder and a bigger voice when it comes
to determining how Germany in the next
few months in the near future deals with
the coronavirus pandemic many thanks our
political correspondent Thomas Sparrow
in Berlin